Speaker 1: I have some fascinating
audio and video to play for you.
In the midst of the January six committee
hearings, Rudy Giuliani said on his podcast,
which was released right as the House committee
was holding its hearings. Rudy puts out a podcast
and he says he admits to the entire thing. He
says the whole point of the rally on January 6th
and of subsequently going down to the Capitol,
the point of it, the goal of it, the objective
was to try to get electoral votes that
Donald Trump didn't actually earn.
Listen to the language Rudy uses here. Okay.
You really have to this is one of those it's
linguistically important to listen to the words.
Speaker 4: Used when the president put out the
first notice of this rally, which actually was
somewhere in mid-December for a January six
rally. On the day that the Electoral College vote
was going to be taken. The whole purpose of it was
a rally in support of the president's
bid for electoral votes in the sense that
he had proven and shown that he had really
won these states and he was being deprived
of these states unfairly and illegally.
Speaker 1: A bid. The point of the rally
was to support Trump's bid for electoral votes.
You don't bid for electoral votes. You either won
them or you didn't. And it is really I know
the eggman is going to write in about it.
It's Kafka esque language. You don't make a bid
for electoral votes. You don't make a case for
electoral votes. You don't argue about electoral
votes. You don't rally. You either win them or you
don't. How do you how can a rally of people saying
things be an argument for electoral votes? You
either won them or you didn't. And if you think
that something was wrong, you fight it in court.
That's the venue where you fight it, where Trump
tried to fight it. And I believe it was 68 cases,
63 or 68 cases that he lost. That's the one venue
where you argue for electoral votes. And it's an
admission that the whole point of what happened
on January six was to try to get votes you didn't
actually win. End of story. Case in point. And
Rudy Giuliani admitting to the entire thing.